[Music]
first of all you should have Java 8 in
your system to run selenium 3.0 3 plus I
mentioned so you should have Java 8 if
you want to run selenium 3 plus ok you
can verify whether you have Java on
version 8 plus or not by going to
command command say Java - version and
then see if you have the latest version
of Java or not if you don't have
downloaded from the link provided right
here and install that in your system and
configure it second selenium 3 point 3
point 1 is mentioned right here but now
the latest version is frequent five
point three you can simply download the
latest version whatever you get from the
selenium website okay here it is talking
about testing gee so we'll be talking
about testing gee at the later point
then we will be talking about unit
testing framework so as of now you don't
need to download it no need ok you don't
need to download it just setup selenium
and Java and your system and make it
ready because from now onwards we'll be
writing the script selenium now let's
talk about the project setup steps so
first create a new Java project and
given name second create a new source
folder and provide this table name the
source folder is automatically created
only to worry about signal right click
on test source folder create a new
package and provide a suitable name this
script so here we will be going create a
new package via board we already have a
package that is called as selenium
examples so we will use it right click
on test source folder create a new
folder and name it as resources right
click on the project create a new folder
and name it as lip so why they are
calling it as resources and why they are
calling it as left let me tell you that
so they are asking us to create two new
folders in the project so by saying new
folder give it a name resources
and this resources we will be going to
keep all our drivers at ass chromedriver
- cyber all those drivers there is also
school it is also asking need to create
very different it is also asking me to
create one more folder that is called as
Lib okay so in this lab will be going to
store all our selenium libraries okay so
earlier how we set up so there are two
ways to set up one is you are going to
the project go to properties shower
build path add external jars and you
select the libraries that you want to
add okay the second one is you go to Lib
we don't go you just create a lip folder
you go here copy the libraries paste it
here inside this after pasting it doing
the right-click do the right-click and
say say see there's that let's see I
come to see what here why I'm not
getting that option can try it right now
if you would like so download the
libraries create a new folder right in
this in a project by creating the folder
you will get here live and you can taste
all your libraries right into this
folder and then you can select the your
library
Guga right click and then you will get
an option add to build path you can then
add your libraries directly to your
build path so how it helps it actually
helps you to manage all your libraries
add in one project and it will be
configured in your project how to add
libraries into the lip folder just copy
the library come here and paste it and
done so here if I go to live folder copy
it and paste it
and then it will be added or you can do
the right click go to properties copy
this path the location where this lip
folder is present you can copy it paste
it here and here you can paste your
libraries this is also an option
after that you select your libraries to
the right click and there you will get
an option add to build path ok and then
the libraries will be added to the very
path
we might I would suggest you try
yourself as well it will be there in
your in your eclipse you won't you won't
face any issues like I am person so
that's what we do it is just that we do
create like lady here so that we can
maintain in all the libraries in one
folder in the same project instead of
you-know-who and explore like theories
or search for the life it is the second
it's completely there is no difference
you can use any way you can use any
approach just that when you do the right
click in the project and go to
properties and do add external charge
then it is getting added from some
different location but here you are
creating a folder in your own project
where you are working so you don't need
to go here and there to search for the
libraries that's a yes
it goes to the reference library energy
after you add it to the build path it is
you know adding it to the adding files
to the left reference library it is same
no difference do the setup okay
today itself so here you can see they
have created a folder on top of that
they have created two more folder that
is one is source and one is test sources
what that we actually get it there is no
need to create test folder if there is a
leaven comes if you know bill two level
comes then you will see automatically
all these architecture will be created
it's by default comes when you work on
level and this is how they are saying
that your folder such a will look like
this then they are asking us to original
libraries so they are asking us to copy
the downloaded say Liam jaw into the lip
folder like I have shown you this one
they're asking us to add the drivers in
the resources folder so just add the
drivers in the resources folder asking
us to this ant it essentially very just
ignore for the time being will not be
going to do that
and here you can see that guys okay
great obey I hope you must be getting
the build path option and add to build
path by right-clicking on the project so
there are two ways like I mentioned one
is you select all the libraries and say
build path add to build path or another
way is a correctional child files so you
can choose any way it's up to you if you
don't have chrome and ie then install
those browsers as well ways it's for us
well if you don't have I and chrome just
download them as well know so receipt
you don't require any github account to
get DJ co-driver you just what you need
to do is go to J co-driver version and
here you have Windows zip file click on
it and it will download the zip file for
you and that's it done you don't need to
create any kind of a you know any
account and all that if you have an
older version of Firefox and install the
latest version so that we can work on
latest version and guys make sure that
you have chrome in5 point because these
are the main browser people uses and
will be working on all these closures as
well so this is how they are showing us
that you know it has been added so they
have maintained the resources in a
package but we are maintaining it in a
separate folder and it is always
suggested maintain your drivers in a
folder here you can for the time being
you can ignore this a package okay so
let's create this architecture of course
I have the architecture we have already
created that and foreign resources let's
copy the co-driver chromedriver and I
driver as well so let's go to that
selenium resources so here they have
stored all my library all my you know
exe and libraries etc so here I need to
add the Jaco driver how to download
whatever I am repeating it once again
just take a look here for the Jaco
driver click on this version clicked on
it you will get this page go down you
will get a zip file here click on it and
download it and unzip it downloaded and
unzipped that that's
second chromedriver click on the latest
version 2.31
let it open you'll you will get
chromedriver click on the zip file it
will get downloaded and then unzip it
and that's it
after that ye driver support ie driver
just move your cursor up move your
cursor up and here you can see there is
a different section completely Internet
Explorer driver server ok so click on
64-bit windows IE when you click on it
it will start downloading the ie driver
server and done so all the three drivers
are downloaded and now you can unzip
them and after unzipping you can add
them to your resource folder so checker
driver copy this pasted in resource
folder go back
let's see chrome drivers this is my
chrome driver let me go inside it copy
this again paste it here control V going
back internet explorer driver server
open this copy it they said and done all
the three drivers has been placed in the
folder you don't need to add them into
the build path ok you won't add them
into the build path so you just need to
add the libraries into the build path
not the resources ok ok all the setup is
done no more setup is required now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here